né à paris est issu d'une fratrie de
clubs frères et soeurs vous passé les 20
premières années de votre vie dans la
région à tours où vous commencez dès
votre adolescence à tourner des courts
métrages amateurs
cette passion pour le grand écran vous
la vivez pleinement en intégrant à la
fin des années 60
l'institut des hautes études
cinématographiques votre formation
aiguise votre regard sur le septième art
et vous écrivez quelques critiques pour
les cahiers du cinéma
les réaliser aussi de nombreux spots
publicitaires touche-à-tout vous écrivez
est dessiné en 1970 pour le journal
pilote dirigé par l'auteur de bandes
dessinées gotlib et ce pendant cinq ans
deux de ses personnages vous inspire
et vous en fait une adaptation
audacieuse avec coluche et jean
rochefort dans les wc était fermée de
l'intérieur
le succès vient avec le film culte les
bronzés dans lequel vous réunissez la
troupe du splendid et je mets au défi
les gens qui verront ce film oublié
s'ils ne savent pas que c'est une pièce
quantifie 2 dire oui c'est ainsi que la
finlande 2 5e j'attends suit une série
de comédies tout très populaire bien
chez moi j'habite chez une copine ma
femme s'appelle reviens ou encore
circulez ya rien à voir
et puis vous choisissez de multiplier
les registres tantôt policiers avec
giraudeau et lanvin dans les analystes
tantôt dramatique avec le mari de la
coiffeuse est ridicule qui couronnait
des césar du meilleur réalisateur et du
meilleur film curieux vous vous lancer
aussi dans le film d'animation avec le
magasin des suicides
vous savez vous entouré des plus grands
et les plus grands aime tourner pour
vous sans doute parce qu'ils apprécient
votre humour et votre simplicité